[Musique]
légaliser le cannabis c'est l'engagement
électoral de justin trudeau
nous allons légaliser la marijuana les
provinces doivent obtempéré et au québec
on ne veut pas que ça incite plus de
gens à consommer une question de santé
publique et de sécurité
on ne pénalisera pas le produit en ce
moment 15 % des québécois de 15 ans et
plus disent avoir consommé du cannabis
au cours de la dernière année ce sont
les adolescents et les jeunes adultes
qui consomment le plus
et dans toutes les catégories d'âge les
hommes consomment plus que les femmes
parmi ceux qui consomment la moitié
d'île faire moins d'une fois par mois
mais il ya 11 % des gens qu'ils font
tous les jours
à l'échelle du pays c'est à l'île du
prince édouard qu'on consomme le moins
et en colombie-britannique qu'on
consomme le plus au québec on est sous
la moyenne canadienne
ce sont les provinces qui vont décider
qui va pouvoir acheter du cannabis et
qui va pouvoir en vendre
l'ontario et l'alberta ont déjà présenté
leurs plans en ontario c'est l'état qui
va assurer la distribution du cannabis
alors qu'en alberta
on pourrait autoriser certaines
entreprises privées à le faire en
ontario il va être défendue de consommer
dans les lieux publics
alors qu'en alberta ça va être autorisée
à certains endroits
au québec la réglementation risque de
ressembler à celle de l'ontario
c'est le premier ministre qui l'a dit il
y aura des points communs évidents entre
les deux approches meilleur parfois des
petites différences mais sécurité
routière consommation en milieu de
travail lutte contre le crime organisé
beaucoup reste à faire en peu de temps
québécois ont une certaine inquiétude
ils ont besoin d'être rassurés mais
malgré les appels répétés de plusieurs
provinces
ottawa reste inflexible le cannabis sera
légalisé au plus tard le 1er juillet
prochain
ici ou là vallée radio canada québec